this is Startalk okay he says Allen
turnings early work Turing Ali did you
miss read that off that is now spread
that's misspelled okay okay Alan Turing
Turing Turing early work was on
self-organization organizing systems
given a cosmic perspective would entropy
give way to equilibrium and then begin
self-organization or is the elegant
order we see in the universe just
Newtonian so is it all grass some these
people are doing their home some people
are doing their home yeah yeah check it
out I got to tell you man Brian you're
making me work here that deep right so
let me let me let me sort of unpack this
please do all right so the universe as
we expand is cooling right the entropy
is increasing this is the disorder in
the universe all right and so so you can
ask if you have disorder how do you have
if disorder is increasing how do you
ever have order you get disorder if
there's no source of energy pumping into
the system that's it it's that simple
so why is there order on earth why is
there life why is there complex life
rather than complete disorder because we
were in orbit around a Sun that is
providing energy right but in the big
picture the Sun will ultimately die or
at and it will not regenerate and
anything on earth would then also die
along with die along with it right
because that was our source of energy
propping up the complexity of our
systems against the the disorder that
would otherwise ensue right so so it's
it's only about where did you what is
your source of energy and what is not
that's all it comes down to
that's his stars are a great source of
energy they last a long time they're
very efficient and so that's why you can
have pockets of complex stuff going on
there the LED light bulbs of the
universe they keep on going just keep on
going yeah right yeah so there's a
stretch there but I'm helping you I'm
saying okay relatable you know by the
way on the subject of
the Nobel Prize in Physics yes for 19
for 2014 was on the discovery of blue
LEDs which gave us white light is that
what it is uh he gave us it allows us to
have light yes it because we had red
LEDs right and green and green LEDs
that's rrg au:g we need to be I need
that big there's to be think RGB gives
you white and every other color in the
spectrum sweet Nobel Prize Nobel Prize
that's all it was - it's just one little
color got you a Nobel Prize if I had
known that you could have done that long
ago please kidding me that's all it took
was one little color